the Joe Rogan experience imagine when
when you think about the original Lucca
and then human beings do you ever try to
extrapolate you ever try to like keep
the the process rolling in your mind and
see where it where's this gonna go oh
yeah said the end of the book I paint a
not so rosy picture of what was going
well yeah so let's talk about the end of
the book so okay I you know say okay
well our we have these two kinds of
significant experiences in our lives
that that occupy the human mind one is
the kind that we can call an awareness
of facts you know I this thing is here
and the other is what we might call a
self awareness where it's it's me that
is aware that that is a bottle so that's
a that's a higher level and that is what
appears to be unique to the human mind
the ability to represent the self as a
subject in other words to have these
subjective experiences that have a
personal past it's not just the past but
your past you lived it and a personal
present and a potential future that you
can imagine different scenarios of you
existing in in the future so that
requires I mean that's called Auto
noetic consciousness the ability to to
self know about where you are in time
and it depends that this is an idea that
was proposed by a guy named Endel
talling a very distinguished
psychologist who's retired now but his
idea was that the unique aspect of of
the human mind is mental time travel the
ability to project ourselves in the past
present and future and without that kind
of consciousness were limited to kind of
factual information something is there
you know that might I might be able to
say oh food is there or drink is there
or a sexual partner is there but not
necessarily
that I want that food I want you know
you might have a kind of biological urge
towards it now from the outside it looks
like everything we do is intentional and
willful so I think I'm controlling my
behavior you think you're controlling
yours I see you do something that I
might have done in a similar situation I
think you intentionally control that we
see a dog doing something that would be
similar to what we do we think we know
why the dog is doing that because it had
some intention but the fact is if we
start taking these things apart in the
brain we see that the systems that
control very simple behaviors or not the
ones that are doing all this high-level
conscious thought take the example of
the area I work on for all these years
which is threat detection now the part
of the brain called the amygdala is key
to the detection in response to threat
in a kind of basic sense you know a
threat comes up you freeze if there's a
snake for example now it's all because
of that it's been assumed that the
reason you freeze is because you're
afraid and therefore that the amygdala
is also making the fear because they
make de la experiences the fear and
that's why you produce the response but
I've threatened for the longest time in
throughout most of my career I've said
the amygdala does not consciously
experience fear and yet my work has been
used to kind of sell and and defend this
idea of the amygdala is the brains fear
center I think that's completely wrong
the why do you think it's been
misinterpreted it's a long complicated
story but did you know it's partly it's
my fault because I was not as vigilant
as I should have been when I was
described need to see what I did was I I
would talk about the amygdala as a non
conscious state of fear non conscious
implicit fear and I would say that while
the neocortex is where we consciously
experience fear and those are separate
but that was too complicated the other
journal is kind of ignored it and it was
just it just became the amygdala the
brains fear center even the scientists
ignored it because you know we were
studying and you know I kind of gave up
after I said okay we talked about it in
terms of fear because you know that
there was a lot of money to be directed
towards research if you're studying fear
and how you could treat that but I think
it's you know it's been kind of a wrong
path because it's led to the development
of medications that don't really work so
all the big companies are getting out of
the anti-anxiety business anti for your
business because people still feel
fearful or anxious when they take them
you mean like xanax yeah these are
getting out of those annex business
benzos xanax I mean they're not either
that are repurposing them for other
purposes yeah but so what happens is you
the way these things you know these
things the basic drugs were discovered
in the 60s almost accidentally in some
cases you know not rather than by some
hypothesis so the only thing that's been
discovered since then is more versions
of the same thing with you know slightly
fewer side effects there's been no new
discovery of a new kind of drug that's
going to help people and why is that
well the way the drugs are discovered is
that take a rat or a mouse put it in a
challenging situation
give it some different medications and
the ones that make the animal less timid
in those situations is assumed to make
the animal less fearful that's why it's
less timid so when you give it to a
person they should be less fearful but
what you find is say a person's social
anxiety might find it easier to go to
the party and they're less timid but
still anxious while they're there and
the reason is that we now know is that
damage to the amygdala in a person
doesn't necessarily also eliminate the
feeling of fear it gets rid of the the
body responses but not to feel mmm so it
was a misunderstanding of what behavior
can tell us we treat behavior as if it's
an ambassador of the
but behavior is really a tool of
survival it goes back to those first
cells that ever lived who had to defend
against danger bacterial cells move in
there in the water and then they come
across like you know a gradient of some
chemical that's a toxin as soon as they
detect that they bounce away and go in a
different direction if they go if they
find a gradient of something that is a
nutrient they keep going and and absorb
it so they have the ability to detect
what's useful and harmful in their lives
these are not these are not there for
psychology they're simply there to keep
the organism alive and many of the
behaviors that persist throughout the
whole history of life or like that
they're there because each of the cell
and cells in the body has to you know do
all these things to stay alive and so
the organism as a whole has to do it as
well defend against danger incorporate
nutrients balanced LeWitt's
thermoregulate reproduce so these are
survival tools not mind tools now we can
use our mind in conjunction with these
things and because we can we conflate
every time we're freezing in the front
of a snake till the fact that the fear
is what's causing it but the fear is a
separate process it's the awareness that
that stuff is happening to you the
awareness that that stuff is happening
to you so it said no self no fear oh
that's my t-shirt
[Applause]